Tucker Carlson sends legal threat to Pac
urging him to run four presidents kind
of interesting move here by his lawyers
um
so Tucker Carlson's lawyer harmeet Dylan
has issued a legal threat to the draft
uh Tucker pack stating that Carlson will
not run for president 2024 under any
circumstances they'll warn the group to
seize its effort and vow to use legal
means to protect Carlson's rights and
supporters the draft Tucker pack
released a video on ad urging Tucker to
run for president praising his his
ability to combat leftists in both
parties parties and comparing him to the
late Rush Limbaugh Dylan responded on
Twitter declaring that The Pact was
unauthorized and criticizing Newsmax for
airing the ad she warned donors about
being deceived and urged them not to
contribute to the pack this pack is
unauthorized fruitless to contribute
getting ripped off they owe their
viewers better than this rap look it's a
scam pack and obviously it's a scam pack
and in harmony
is a deeply deeply intelligent woman so
she knows what's going on here and what
a lot of people don't understand about
the political world is like number one
it's full of grifters uh and it's full
of people that are running hustles and
running grips and so you got a bunch of
people probably nobody knows who is
behind this scam pack but a bunch of
people that had enough money to put
together to to you know run ads on
Newsmax and they're basically saying
we're going to use Tucker's name and
we're gonna bring in all of this money
nobody knows who these people are nobody
knows where this money is going whatever
it's a scam harmeet saw it Tucker saw it
and they're like they want to put it
into it and is this normal is this
common it just happens oh my God in the
swamp cut oh my goodness is this are
they trying to is this a an organization
that sincerely wants to help Tucker run
or no they're just trying to make some
money I believe that these people are
trying to make money and they're trying
to use the biggest name in in our space
probably one of the biggest names in
America to do it this is what Sebastian
Gorka was talking about yesterday with
Trump and how basically the parasites
just basically yeah
and just trying to siphon off money from
Trump World they are political
consultants and if it's an even year
even numbered year they make even more
money yep and they make money whether or
not their candidates win or lose that's
what people do not understand about the
swap like the pollsters I don't have to
be right yeah they don't have to be I
just have to be
retained yeah these people are scammers
they're grifters the swamp is full of
these people and they will take a big
name and they will use that name to make
money because the the and this is what I
don't like about this entire situation
is that they literally they
underestimate the intelligence of the
audience of the Maga base of whatever
and in their minds in the minds of some
of these scammers the Maga base is a
bunch of Rubes um to be grifted
interesting all right well
um I can tell you there's a lot of
people that would like to see the guy
run but I know that's not what he wants
to do he wants a different life if he
did I think he's got a big follow and I
actually think it would bump into the
number two spot really overnight I think
he's that powerful of a guy and likable
because remember the key word is what
winning you win the people you win your
freedom he's one people he's one people
it's the hardest thing to do so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]